yeah う
潤うーん
はいっ
おばあちゃんはじめ冊というわけであの
ん
クマですというところでもそうだったんですけども大きいんですよねこの巨大なクマの
ぬいぐるみ大きすぎるんですけども
この子オーバーっはいああああああ
だったがいました
からやりすぎたご覧くださいもういいなぁこの広めの部屋もう全部つまで埋まって
しまいました愛的で2m 越えのかなさんのぬいぐるみ14体ほど20万円分くらい
買いました
なんでこんなにたくさん買ったかといいますと排気んですね家の近くに引っ越してきた
プラベずの新メンバーの人がいるんですけどもうお祝い引っ越し祝いなにあげようか
なくずっと考えていた時に寂しいですよ引越ししたての時ってをのと角度が少ないから
出て寂しいんでそんな寂しいメンバーたちにステッキがプレゼント大きな熊さん
プレゼントしたら絶対喜ぶと思うんですよというわけで引っ越せしたりの何もないやに
大きな熊さん
全部プレゼントしちゃうん
女は9位たって迷惑まあまあ嬉しいと思うんですけどうれしいと迷惑のはすぐ中間です
や迷惑よりかなぁこんな命令な世界普通に楽しいと思うんですけどもまぁ生活する分に
はとても名誉のサプライズプレゼントにターゲットがどこまで喜んでくれるのかやって
みたいと思います
いやーこれメルヘンよもう太鼓よこんなところがだけのことない
入ってくる時ぐらいにサプライズでおうちの中熊さんで開くで帰っているサプライズ
ハッピーこれでやってみたいと思いますくそめんどくさいけどがんばりますこれます
う
ん邪魔しもうわー
新居っぽう the 新居だなぁ
いやーこの何もない感じが本当にガチャ寂しいので大きな釜でいっぱいに
しまう
では輸送します1匹ずつ持ってみましょう
あううっと遠くはないんですけど違う誰でもまあちょっと普通にやばいんだ
強めバー
ん
んですよ
を尊重されないでしょうかいはぁ
これは多いデー
[音楽]
ん
これ何も突っ込んでるのがいいぞ
てさぁふふ
[音楽]
答えをいたらだいたいこの1名は埋まっちゃう感じです
半分も入ってねっ
[音楽]
要素
4 c
くっさー
よっしゃ置き場所がもう何か
ねもうどこに置けばいいん
なんてもに混ぜを今日じゃないんだよ手水ねいちゃー
はぁ
じゃあ用紙残り2体になりました
ん小野寺と諸星4社とこいつら運んで終わりです
[音楽]
じゃーんこれでぜひこういうふうに座りズラーッ
ジョーズ3声これどうすねーこれこれやばいなパッと見アホの家みたいになってしまい
ましたこれでさすがにこのままだとちょっとなんか汚いしてかわいそうなんでしっかり
とくまちゃんたちをいい感じに配置していい感じねこう感動する形でおいたわけですね
セッティングっていきます
[音楽]
ワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワン
扉を開ける
[音楽]
くまの爆炎や主の王女迎え入れてくれるんです
なるべくすべてのこの顔が出るように配置しました
これには佐世保のターゲットも関係あること間違いないでしょ
これぞ最高の空間
これでも新居は寂しくありませんターゲットが来たらさぞ
もう悲しみの毎日が一転したかのようにとっても喜ぶこと間違いないと思います
ターゲットの北高待ちましょ
[音楽]
ua
ん
やっぱ
[音楽]
分
11匹
ゆ中1匹どころじゃないかこれきゃわーもっといたした物体るっ
いらねー
まず増
[音楽]
ブーブー
でそうなるとズってそうすぐに
レンチも場所になって保険から背景他に引っ越して来なかったっけな
kyoi がおおーーちょうど最近新居に引っ越してきました
持って号配布かよね
ん
4日ですでは間違いない客様ってあったんですよねー
これはえーっ多分接客寂しいかなと思って
はいっ
たくさんズームしたよあ崩れ者やすごいなぁ
これ代物ですねナビたいねー
どれさその後3つロイコレ
ぶーぶーっ
[音楽]